this shop in istanbul has been a refuge
for mccarran since she and her daughter
left northwest china five years ago
her husband and two other children were
left behind in ching young she hasn't
heard from them since
she fears a u.n report that condemns
china's treatment of uyghurs and other
muslim minorities will largely go
ignored
it's been five years of us living here
china has killed our young people and
left our children orphaned the united
nations isn't doing enough
michelle bachelet released the report 13
minutes before her term as u.n human
rights chief ended it found that uyghurs
and other mostly muslim groups and
detention camps have been subjected to
torture including forced medical
treatment and sexual and gender-based
violence
this is not a case of turks or uighurs
or muslims or jews this is a case of
humanity we're not calling for china to
stop just because we're uyghurs any
person with a heart and brain must know
that this is wrong
china has denied any abuses it says his
policies in qing young fight what it
calls terrorism and provides uighurs
with better economic opportunities
the so-called assessment is orchestrated
and produced by the us and some western
forces and is completely illegal and
void
countless stories of torture and
separation are shared within the uyghur
community
abdusalam says he hasn't heard from his
brother in five years
this report should have come out earlier
this isn't something that can be put on
hold when a group is being destroyed
it's not appropriate for humanity just
to watch for a couple of years
the report recommends the chinese
government take steps to release uyghurs
detained in training centers prisons or
detention facilities the uyghur
community hopes for the same but fears
their cause will largely be ignored at
home
and abroad katya lopez
al jazeera